[Music]
stephen hawking was on big bang yeah and
i got to imagine you did you get to meet
stephen hawking i did i did get to meet
him and it was really it was so surreal
i i had done an impression of him in the
uh in the pilot and a few times
throughout the show and so
you know we had always mentioned him
he'd always been sort of obviously this
dream guest and they got him and he had
shot a scene at caltech and he wanted to
watch a run through a rehearsal and
he they asked if it was okay with us uh
for this
genius to come down and we of course
said yes and it was just so surreal they
opened the giant stage doors and he was
like silhouetted from behind
and he had this entourage it's like a
rock star it really was it was like this
man in a wheelchair and all these cool
british guys behind him and they asked
if we wanted to meet him and they put
out his hand and we shook his hand and
then i had to do this scene where i did
an impression of him
for him in front of and it's kind of you
know that would imagine that i mean it's
you know he's he's severely disabled and
i
am kind of making fun of his voice right
right you know it's
that kind of thing and and so i have to
do this thing
where i in front of him and it had to be
cl i asked the producers to clear it to
make sure yeah make sure that this is
something he is okay with i mean i
didn't want him to stand up and beat me
no i
i
no i don't did not want to pick on him
yeah exactly he's brilliant and and it's
not fair i did the impression i my heart
was beating through my chest and i stood
up and saluted him after in the middle
of the scene and he smiled and it was
like the crate it was really really one
of the creatures it all worked out he's
a huge fan of the show he is a huge fan
and he really lit up when he got to meet
kaylee from the show um